Donald Trump has reportedly fired or had pushed
out Dr. Rick Wright, who was leading the effort
to develop a Corona virus vaccine, allegedly
because Rick Wright was refusing to promote
chloroquine.
Trump's preferred Corona virus treatment,
at least up until a week ago.
It was truly stunning and disgusting.
There are two sides to the story, I'll tell
you both of them.
Dr. Rick Bright was the head of Baabda, the
Biomedical Advanced Research and Development
Authority since 2016.
On Tuesday, he was abruptly reassigned to
a narrower position.
He says he was removed and transferred because
he resisted promoting chloroquine, which Trump
had been promoting for weeks until multiple
studies showed.
It's not only ineffective in treating Corona
virus, it may be dangerous to people if they
have Corona virus.
Bright admits that he was against pushing
for promoting chloroquine, saying, quote,
specifically, and contrary to misguided directives,
I limited the broad use of chloroquine and
hydroxy chloroquine promoted by the administration
as a panacea which clearly lacked scientific
merit.
While I am prepared to look at all options
and to think outside the box for effective
treatments, I rightly resisted efforts to
provide an unproven drug OnDemand to the American
public.
I insisted that these drugs be provided only
to hospitalized patients with confirmed COVA
19 while under the supervision of a physician.
These drugs have potentially serious risks
associated with them, including increased
mortality observed in some recent studies
in patients with Cauvin 19.
That's right.
Trump was talking about what do you have to
lose?
Maybe take it prophylactically.
That, unfortunately, is not, though, what
you you're supposed to say when you are under
the thumb of the great leader, Donald Trump,
who says chloroquine for everyone, maybe with
a zee PAC, maybe with zinc or both.
Now, Trump, of course, played dumb during
yesterday's press briefing.
And I have thoughts on this.
Here's how Donald Trump responded when asked
about Dr. Rick Bright.
Rick, right.
He's the head of the federal agency in charge
of getting a vaccine out to two Americans
once it's ready.
He says he has been pushed out of his job
because he raised questions about eyedrops,
chloroquine by Samir Directress on that.
Was he pushed out?
I never heard of him.
You just mentioned the name.
When did this happen?
This happened today.
This guy says he was pushed out of a job.
Maybe he was.
Maybe he wasn't.
I did have to hear the other side.
I don't know who he is.
So my instinct is it's possible Trump doesn't
know the guy's name, but he's familiar with
the situation.
It's possible that this came up as one of
10 things someone brought to Trump.
And Trump said remove him and he genuinely
doesn't remember.
It's possible that this was the action of
someone in the Trump administration and not
of Donald Trump himself who made the decision
to get rid of Rick Bright.
I mean, there's a few different options here.
It's also possible Trump is just lying.
He lies all the time.
And it wouldn't be surprising to see Donald
Trump just straight up lie about this, even
though he knows exactly who Dr. Rick Bright
is.
I don't know.
Now to be thorough.
There is another narrative here, which is
a counter narrative.
The narrative is that the Trump administration
did reassign Rick Bright, but it wasn't because
of the chloroquine thing that they've actually
there's a report that they've been trying
to get rid of him in this position for a year,
and they finally succeeded this week.
The timing is certainly suspect.
Will we ever know the truth?
Probably not.
But Dr. Rick Bright is filing a complaint
with the inspector general.
Of course, we know how inspector generals
have been neutered under the Trump administration
as well.
Next, I do want to talk about how Donald Trump
was once again triggered by CBS News reporter
Wagih a Jang related to the doctor Rick Bright's
story.
Check
this out.